there are reports from Portugal that
police looking for Madeleine McCann are
to begin searching a dam in Portugal
which is 50 kilometers from where she
went missing back in 2007. German
officers will be joined by a team from
Portugal and offices from the UK while
the British three-year-old went missing
while on holiday and prior to luge 16
years ago let's get more from ashnahonag
in The Newsroom actually this is just
developing this storybook but what do we
know about why this search is
potentially going to happen we have been
hearing this from our colleagues in
Portugal at Jane we understand that this
search will take place tomorrow and it's
going to focus on a dam as you say some
50 kilometers away from prior to luge in
The Algarve it is our understanding
there in Portugal that tomorrow they
will begin what is due to be a two-day
search at the request of German police
and the team specifically investigating
The Disappearance of Madeleine McCann